it's just after close of World War one
and foreign scientists get look at Mount
Wilson Observatory near Pasadena California
Hilton cat walk around dome is interesting
but what scientists see through this 40 inch
telescope then world's largest it's far more
fascinating here man is exploring distant
skies in search of wonders and far-off worlds
here's professor van respect readying
camera that will take pictures of what
telescope sees hundreds of millions of
miles away stars of Amir twinkles in
the sky are gigantic wording worlds as big
as or bigger than ours yes worst photo our
famous Andromeda nebula still too far
away to be studied even by telescopes
so in 1934 in Corning New York scientists
launched work on gigantic 200-inch lands
that will see world's yet unknown to man for
months the glass cools and then in December
1935 is declared perfect and plans were made to
ship finish lens to Palomar it's precision job
not till November 1936 is lens loaded on
railroad car for five months journey to
California world waits for glimpse of
heavens through its most gigantic eye